community typically likes it good
morning everybody sighs no hassle
chairman of nahas and capacity group
based in Syria is a compelling subsidies
in Lebanon Jordan is Sudha when the
horse as a year the founding member of
the horse I think the important thing we
should target for is just if we have
just again really have peace and when I
please protect place then prosperity and
welfare take this the region the Middle
East is very strategic area and
unfortunately the oil where a fortune
but now became a problem hood and
everybody is moving how to get around it
sorry I wish they'd pay for the patrol
moving backward in different ways and
films I don't know the details but
carino well he's on supplies immediately
what are they going
within these billions of arms guns what
whom they are going to fight with this
means very simple the Pentagon must be
repaid back from these countries I was
the captain a particular and they have
to be back for us right now for the
future one thing is important to remain
faithful pc will take place then and
just like this that this we take place
and then this will having the welfare by
for everyone for the tech please